here are three reasons why AI will never
replace copywriters number one is
relationships especially as an email
copywriter the relationship you have
with your list and your people is far
more important than the writing itself I
like to say people buy you before they
buy your product number two is
personality whether you're witty or zany
or funny or dry or whatever it is people
are attracted to people like them and so
if you're introverted extroverted you're
going to see more of those type of
people relate to you on your list and
read your copy that is attractive and
number three is storytelling AI has no
stories it has no past life it has no
experiences that it could draw upon and
inject into the copy that is relatable
to the people reading it and so you have
the most powerful tool at your disposal
Humanity